[Music]
some killers act from a desire to exert
their will over others some to satisfy
carnal urges or even to quiet the voices
in their heads
Leatherface does as he's told his family
loves him and that is all that matters
outsiders are a threat and threats need
to be dealt with he is now in a place
that is familiar but hard to understand
but he instinctively knows what he has
to do
outsiders will come and he will use his
skills to overcome them there will be
screaming but he will make the world
quiet again
until the only sound remaining is the
Blessed howl of the soul Leatherface his
power is called Bubba's chainsaw when
incredibly powerful and heavy chainsaw
which sank it's deep into countless
victims a suiting birthday gift
to the cannibal Leatherface comes with
three perks
the first one is knock out the trauma
caused by your brutal attacks makes
crying for help painfully difficult
dying survivors auras are not revealed
to other survivors when they are
standing outside of a certain range the
second perk is called barbecue and chili
a deep bond with the entity unlocks
potential in ones or a reading ability
after hooking a survivor all other
survivors auras are revealed to you for
a few seconds as long as they are far
away from the hook that grants a hundred
percent bonus blood points on any
scoring event while a survivor is on the
hook the third perk is called Franklin's
demise your vicious attacks make the
survivors drop their items on impact the
lost item is damaged in the fall losing
a percentage of its base amount of
charges
Leatherface kills because he's scared
scared that his family will be
displeased with him scared that their
shared desire to eat human flesh will be
discovered
Leatherface is available now